I also have a bunch of colors I'm going
to be using a whole lot of them just for
this opening part here so let's focus
first on the interpreting we'll get to
be constructing the later in the
exercise okay remember what this is
called this is a.m. 4 a.m. 4 which is
about modeling linear relationships so
the idea is you've got two quantities do
you wanna and we want to be able to
produce a model it's nice it's simple
enough to interpret but we can still use
to solve problems I want us to remember
when you have a look at something like
this which you guys actually told me on
on Monday you reminded me all we've
looked at these kinds of things before
when you're thinking about straight
lines we represent with these guys I
want you to remember what all four of
those pruning rules actually mean so you
know how on a Cartesian plane you've got
two axes each one is represented by one
of these but which one is which which
one's the up/down one so Y okay I'll
come to that in a second I promise I'll
get to that is just my color okay
so this guy here this is the up-down so
we're gonna say this is the vertical
axis and then you've got your horizontal
one or even your color which of course
is the X right so this one is our side
to side one here horizontal and so we
compare x and y values coordinates
according to the different axes and then
we come to M and B now it's really
important we remember x and y are
variables they can change but in and be
in a particular situation they are
actual numbers we choose them like three
and negative one or a hundred and
eighteen they're numbers and they don't
change in a particular question so I
said you you said B B stood for what
does it represent very good which in
this context because why we just
remembered is about the vertical axis
iliza
Thanks that means it's really the
intercept on the vertical axis and
that'll be really important down here
and that leaves us with em thank
goodness I have one last color
what is Emma signify gradient very good
so the worst chosen abbreviation of all
time because what does M have to do with
gradient gradient also known as slope so
this is how steep or shallow the light
is whether the line is increasing or
decreasing so that's what each of these
four quantities means now let's think
about an actual situation so for example
think about say the costs according to
say the number of kilometers you've
driven in a taxi plus a plus a fee for
actually flag in the taxi and actually
getting them to come to you okay if we
label each of these right then n the
number of the number of actual cost per
kilometer is like some cents per
kilometer right that's actually a cost
that's a rate isn't it it's like
kilometers per minute or kilometers per
side dollars per Kalon I don't with
dollars per minute so this guy here n
for the number is really a rate so it's
not just like gradient means something
geometrically on the graph but here if
you actually have a model and if you
read that and it said like 0.1 X then
the rate is 0.1 dollars per kilometer or
dollars per minute or whatever it
happens to be the key thing is that we
can interpret it it's not just a
gradient like some visual thing this has
a meaning in a particular situation over
here on the left hand side this guy here
if we said Seifer cost then this is what
we call the dependent variable do you
remember this phrase it's something that
changes it varies but it depends on
something else which I'm going to get to
in a second okay so the cost is a
dependent variable in this case it's
variable because it changes depending on
how far you go how long you're in the
taxi and it's dependent because what it
depends on is
I saw the value over here okay if cost
is the dependent variable what does that
make X wrong color it's the end of a row
it can change however it pleases and so
on the horizontal axis that's what you
labeled accordingly so X might be say
time or distance and the key is that it
changes independently and this is what
changes in response to that so we call
it the independent variable okay
now lastly there's F okay now I said for
example when you're flying a taxi you
wave it down they they charge you this
cost no matter how far or close you're
going to go so in other words what's my
color orange in other words and this is
why I've called it F not just for a flag
for or fee it's a fixed quantity of some
kind a fixed quantity you can see that
this value over here isn't going to
change if I have X's a hundred or X is
zero
it stays whatever number is no matter
how long you go so it's a fixed quantity
I'm going to say quantity rather than
cost or distance or that kind of thing
because the point is we can use these
equations to model anything okay so you
can see this is just in geometric terms
x and y and all that kind of thing y
intercept they mean something on the
graph but this is and that's why I've
called it interpreting this is what does
it mean in a particular situation so how
do we use this where's my remote have a
look at this which is the first question
in this exercise for me okay you've got
this company that's trying to model a
situation which is to do with costs and
number of ties that they produce okay
the daily cost can be modeled marked
that word so this is going to give us an
idea of what's happening in this
situation using the straight line
equation and there it is okay explain
each term in the formula now that
explanation is exactly what we were
talking about here don't say that it's
the y-intercept what is the y-intercept
actually mean speaking of which was told
this this will do
question together number one what is
which number is the y-intercept in this
case it's 1200 this number on the end
right but what does y-intercept in this
situation actually mean what does it
indicate yeah so if we were to draw this
which I think we are gonna have to do in
Part C when we do draw it 1200 is where
I'm gonna be up and down to collab with
the axis but have a look back up with
the question where is the number $1200 a
PR in the question very good so that's
what we're just saying right you'd have
to spend or they have to spend $1200
every single day regardless of how many
times they actually make just as a quick
question why is there a fixed costs like
that why would then what kinds of things
would contribute to a fixed cost of $200
per day city electricity now
interestingly electricity can have some
fixed costs we've actually talked about
this back in the focus done in resources
I think they call it a what's it called
I forget the name but it's something
they charge you even if you don't use
electricity okay but usually I think we
would say the more electricity you use
the more it's going to cost so I
wouldn't call that a fixed cost what
else might be more fixed in this
situation Renae were you gonna say the
case of people who are there and the
cost of actually having the property
they're not going to change all that
much even if you make more ties they're
just making the machines work it's the
same number of people who are there I'm
just putting that out so that you know
that this 200 ollars it comes from
somewhere it's not just some random
number okay so when we explained this is
part a we would say $1200 is the fixed
daily cost
it doesn't change no matter how many
times you make you can see there's the
3m 3m
now that's one term it says explain each
term so 3m where's the three come from
okay good so you can see that's the rate
remember $3.00 per tie this is dollars
per tie you can see what makes this a
rate your company
in two different quantities right
they're not the same unit so 3n is okay
how would you finish this sentence so
this is the cost is the I would say the
variable cost of producing tires because
it's $3 for every tie so that's why it's
variable because more tires means more
cost as opposed to the fixed cost that
we mentioned up here with 1200 so that's
the actual tire production cost we've
got one last term it's over there on the
left hand side
what's C yeah I think total cost is the
perfect word is the total costs total
running costs of the factory it has to
include your production costs and also
your fixed costs altogether okay
now puppy we can do this pretty quickly
completing this table of values because
they go up in consistent numbers these
numbers are actually going to be quite
simple to do we don't even necessarily
need a calculator
I don't think so we're going to have an
N row number of ties and a C road total
cost here's an easy one the first one if
you don't make any ties it's gonna be
that 1200 that wideness that we were
mentioning before so let me catch up a
little bit there we go if you don't make
any ties your cost will be 1200 okay
we're going up in lots of 50 cuz it's a
bit silly to think about a tire factory
just making one tie at a time so that's
why it's in big chunks so if every tire
cost $3 to make how much adjust the tie
is going to cost just the tires yeah
three times 50 is 150 and you're gonna
add that to the fixed running costs
right so 1,350 and as you can see we go
up by 50 tires every time 50 times
another 50 ties another 50 I put in an
extra column which we don't
so every time you see how we add on 150
dollars we're gonna add on 150 dollars
every time it's gonna form a straight
line when we put these all together
hence the name okay so that'll be 1516
50 you guys can tell me if my numbers
are right when you crunch these on a
calculator if you so prefer okay but I'm
just going up by 150 every single time